counting on somebody else to do the job
you count on somebody else to be there
you coun on somebody else to get it done
you count on somebody else to make it
happen for you and life don't work like
that sooner or later you going to have
your own responsibilities you're not
going to be on
scholarship you're not going to be taken
care of you're not going to be looked
after you're not going to have the
luxuries of all this and you going to
have to go out there and get it on your
own and work your butt off because ain't
nobody going to give you nothing I don't
understand I don't think you understand
what this world consist
of what we just did today was
pathetic all the love that you receive
all the love we receive oh you getting
ready to see that flip and don't get
beside yourself on social media and
start responding to the foolishness
because they're
right they're
right and we practicing
tomorrow God bless